you
discovery well this year we have awarded
a fundamental discovery in cell
physiology for vesicle traffic a major
transport system in the cell at the
press conference I got the impression
that this prize people were a bit quiet
was have many people been waiting for
this price either well people have been
aware of this work you know for decades
and you know the work started in the
1970s and it sort of built throughout
the years so in some ways I'm surprised
that it wasn't you know more more of a
obvious choice but um so it's a
fundamental discovery of cell physiology
and it was not entirely easy for these
investigators when they started so
Schekman for example did yeast genetics
and Rahman was doing biochemistry in
itself in a test tube and soot off was
doing biochemistry and some functional
studies with animal models could you
explain a bit about the vesicular
transport system for our lay audience
Eazy would so think of a cell is sort of
a factory and it needs to produce
proteins and they need to shuttle these
proteins in cargo from one workstation
to the next so each protein can get a
little bit better refined along the way
the fundamental discovery here is how
the packages the molecules that cargo is
shuttled from one compartment in the
cell to the other and how these
molecules can be also exported from the
cell so it's that process which we have
awarded the nobel prizes so what were if
you should the great the key
breakthroughs that make them were the
other Nobel Prize those too young to
know what is
the priests lipsy stuff so Schekman used
yeast genetics and he was studying
temperature senton sensitive mutant
yeast and he could morphologically with
a microscope see that some of the
vesicles in the mutinies were building
up in certain parts of the cell he
understood that that disturbed the
traffic and he went on to identify the
genes that control this traffic that was
a pretty bold approach because at the
time people didn't necessarily think
that studies of yeast would be of
relevance for mammals rothman took a
really bold approach he studied this
process in a test tube now that approach
was met with some skepticism because
people thought that this traffic would
be dependent upon the proximity of the
compartments with each other therefore
you theoretically wouldn't be able to
break up the cell because you'd need to
have an int XL Rothman broke up the
cells and study this in a test tube and
he could show that even in a
reconstituted system he could build up
this interaction between proteins the
protein machinery and study the traffic
of these vesicles in broken cells and
schekman when he came on the scene I
think he recognized that calcium could
be a sensor stood up to me suedhof yes
correct suit off soon soon I've came on
the scene he recognized that calcium
could be a sensor and he was faced with
a situation where all the building
blocks were unknown and so his job was
to really to put functionality and
understand what are the building blocks
said the calcium binds to and how does
that release vesicles in a temporally
controlled
the world of Nobel states that the
prices should be awarded to those who
have confer the greatest benefit of
mankind so in what way does this price
fulfill this criterion well that's true
for all of the prizes and new knowledge
about how we how we are in the world is
a great benefit for mankind this again
is fundamental cell physiology so the
knowledge that we're gaining from this
is applicable to all cells from yeast to
humans showing how ancient this is and
what these individuals have done is
they've uncovered this machinery this
mechanism and that is allowed us to
understand basic physiology but it's
also allowed us to have some insight
into disease progression and prospective
treatments so it's a pretty great
benefit to mankind Bishop perspective
treatments in 2d Jessica give an example
in one area when this right so
understanding the treatments better
would allow you to focus on the
machinery and potentially come up with
drugs for example diabetes it's a
disease where insulin is not released
from the prank curious appropriately so
this is controlled with also the calcium
balls so theoretically one could work in
that area and develop pharmaceuticals to
improve insulin release in tissues like
muscle you have an uptake of sugar into
those cells theoretically one can work
on trying to target that machinery to
have a better interaction of you
transport proteins to take up sugar and
feed the muscle with sugar glucose
so there's a lot of examples of where
this could be why was this price ever
wanted this year well it's a long
journey in terms of the vetting and how
we work and this one is mature and we
you know we felt that we had a
fundamental discovery that was Nobel
Prize worthy and so this is why we're
here today to talk about these laureates
so a lot of these young people watching
right now how would you explain the
importance of this price to a say like a
grade school students okay so if you can
imagine that you were going to go to
school and you were going to take the
bus and the bus showed up but there was
no sign on that bus to tell you where it
was going to take you all those signs on
the bus has disappeared so you'd get
into the bus without having any idea of
where it might take you it might take
you to your school but it might take you
to your parents workplace so imagine
that you'd be Miss sorted and that's a
little bit what this process is because
of this process the passengers the cargo
they get to the right place the school
at the right time so you're not late and
you don't end up at the playground or at
your parents workplace or somewhere else
where you're not supposed to be so this
whole process helps the cell sort
proteins so the information is moved to
the right place
what is the state of knowledge in this
field at this time a little bit of what
I said to you before when when Schekman
started people were skeptical of the
idea of using a yeast model people were
unsure that you'd be able to really even
do these experiments when Rahman started
it was incredibly bold he broke up the
cell study this in a test tube people
were skeptical they didn't think it
could work even with the suit off work
you know the molecules were not on the
table so when did the scientific
community realize the significance of
these phonies a scientist I think are
clever to catch on to what's new in the
field and people have really been
actively engaged in this area for
decades this is a tough area of science
it's been really a tough problem to
solve and so many individuals have been
working in different parts of it so if
you turn our attention to the laureates
mmm james rothman and schekman and tomas
you don't um do you know them yourself I
don't know them at all personally and
I've heard James Rothman lecture but I
don't have any interactions with them
and I'm not collaborating with them but
I'm aware of i sling I'm aware of their
work do you have any idea I mean those
findings that there are more today long
time no 8 is night this what do you what
do they work on now well you know so
some the important work is even coming
even today you know so we have some
papers that have been published in the
90s and the two thousand that are really
of relevance for this work so all of
them are active scientists all of them
are completely engaged in their projects
and they're moving these questions for
work today and personally
what makes you such a Socratic place I
just think it's really fantastic I mean
it's so beautiful the organization of
this traffic in the cell is just
phenomenal and the fact that sells
really require this otherwise they
basically can't survive it's just
phenomenal how cells are able to move
this protein machine proteins from one
place to the other so I mean I just
think the cell biology the cell
physiology is really beautiful finally
passed the Nobel commit to being able to
reach any of the laureates so there has
been a telephone conversation between
urine Hanson and Randy Schekman and
james rothman and sued off hasn't we
have been able to reach him but we're in
we're working out so how do they get oh
you know very humbled delighted
surprised you know you know I'm sure
it's a moment of pause for them wait
thank you so much thank you very much
lava